how's it going guys welcome back to
another episode of how to see make we're
working on the same project we did
before i want to review the previous
episodes if you have no idea what's
going on or no idea what cmake is
because we're now up to cpac and cpac is
just another way to install that is a
little more
kosher i guess a little better for the
non-technical user
because it basically packages everything
up
and does what it needs to do to get it
installed and this works on every os i'm
using linux here so i'm going to have to
show you some screenshots of how it
looks on windows and mac because that's
where it really shines
okay so like people usually want the
little installer thing and that walks
them through and they press next or
whatever and they have the uninstall
option too later if they decide they
want you don't want your software that's
what cpac does
so we're going to go to our
cmakelist.txt the top level one in our
project and all we need to do is add
these five lines at the bottom
well i guess the other thing is we need
to add a license
this whole include here include
install require system libraries
set the cpac resource file license to
your license so i did add a license.txt
uh it just needs to match this name
whatever you add so at this point you do
want a license and that will display to
your user while they're installing it
and make them agree to it you also need
your major and minor version of the
software and then last but not least
include cpec and that is it you just
need that on your top level
along with that license so that's the
only changes we've made since last time
is we added these five lines and we
added this license which i did
as you can see he's not a real license
in my my case i'm just goofing around
and i don't feel like going and putting
and figuring out what license should be
with this so
that's all i put all right i'm gonna put
a new line at the end of this and
as you can see here it's already running
cmake so i'm using visual studio code
here and it's i've got the
extension
i don't know if i've talked about this
before but i've got the extension for
cmake tools the main microsoft one and
that automatically runs and builds
everything anytime you make changes to
cmake so it is going ahead and doing its
stuff and it looks like it did
everything successfully and it is happy
configured and generated
so that's why that's automatically
happening i was using in the previous
episodes i was using these sh files and
if you like those you can continue to
use them but the cmake tools is just
making my life easy okay so now what do
we do
now if you look at the documentation on
cpac it basically tells you at this
point okay when you're ready you run
cpac but you do
have to be in your build directory
because if i run it on my root directory
or the project root directory it just
says generator not specified so i do
have to change directory into build and
then run cpac and then it does this
thing this plain old cpac just uses all
your defaults and it builds
well for linux
what it builds is a tor dot gz
and it also builds atar.z so those are
very similar just depends which one you
want to use so what you could do from
here
is let me look in this file directory
again and you'll see that now there are
these these are basically the installers
it's got this sh thing so i believe all
i have to do if i want to install this
on linux is i just go
and run this
sh file
so dot slash to run it hit the button
and there it goes
it starts the installer for linux and it
has you accept with a yes or no here's
the license of course don't tread on me
snake
so i'm going to accept the license
and
here ask me some more questions so
these are the prompts you get for an
install on linux through command line
it's a little different i'll show you
what it looks like on windows but it's
essentially the same thing it takes you
through prompts as you install it okay
so if you distribute these files to
someone else it's gonna it's probably
gonna build them somewhere else so i'm
just going to say yes here
and there it goes unpacking finished
successfully let's check it looks like
there is a new directory here right
there
so we are going to check that out
let's change directory into it and take
a look in it and we see a bin include
live and share
so we'll change directory into that bin
and we'll see our main program there
and we should be able to just run it
here
let's do a dot slash
and there it is it runs so wherever they
decide to install those two will run so
if you're doing this on windows or mac
if you're it'll be the exact same steps
except you don't have to do the command
line stuff you'll actually get a little
executable installer that's all packed
up and it'll look more like this so if
you're on windows this is a super old
one but basically it'll it'll give you
this little pop-up walkthrough that
you're used to seeing when you install a
windows program and people that aren't
super technical that want to use your
software will love this because they can
just double click the thing
and get all your options and just
install your software and same
with
mac now this is a bit of an old bit of
documentation here so it might be a
little bit different but the big thing
is it just pops up a window and prompts
them through it
and another cool thing is they get the
option to uninstall it so if they want
to uninstall your software it pops up
the uninstall thing for windows and they
can just uninstall it and they're done
they don't need to know about all this
technical stuff of how to compile build
where to find it how to change directory
they just run the thing and it's done so
it's just uh even a better way of
installing your software um of course
linux stays a little technical it's not
super technical i mean you can look up
about tar gz and unzipping and unpacking
and stuff but basically if we like let's
look at this little sh file
that it built and we'll see that
basically what it does is just unpack
this stuff and prompt a bunch of options
uh
here it is
it has a usage
has some more
functions
and yeah this is a lot of stuff i'm not
going to walk through all this but
basically it just goes through and does
all the stuff you would expect tells you
things is a self-extracting archive
and eventually somewhere in here it will
unzip so we'll just search for tar
and see where it does that here it is so
there's the command
with xf
so yeah it eventually it prompts you
through a bunch of stuff and then it
just extracts
you could literally if you don't if you
want to skip through all this and you're
super technical you could just unzip
these to where you want them to go
if you're not super technical you can
just run you can just tell your user hey
just run dot slash this sh thing and the
rest will be prompted and you'll be good
to go
so there you go i don't whoa what's all
this oh this is the targey z file packed
in here that's really weird i didn't
realize they did that
all right well let's skip that let's
don't worry about that
all right so that's it that's the very
very basics of adding cpac in the main
required things now if you're if you
want to go further with cpac and maybe
you're doing this for like a super
professional application i would
recommend digging into a little more
documentation on cpac
or maybe
just finding some more advanced stuff
but everything else is really optional
and really special case
hope you enjoyed this episode i'll see
you guys in the next one and keep on
coding keep on using cmake because it's
awesome and i'll see you in the next
episode